taktischer mega sie es vor allem juzis
die rigotti lucy ist hier weil wir aber
wenn ihnen die beete gehen dann können
sie schon einiges durcheinander bringen
und es macht absolut keinen spaß wenn
man beim gärtner in den katzen kaka parc
du kannst deine bete aber ganz gut
schützen wenn du sie entweder mit einem
vlies abdeckst mit einem gemüse
schutznetz oder mit maschendraht damit
die katzen gar nicht erst rein kommen
was auch gut hilft ist wenn man die
beete dickmilch der mit die katzen nicht
mehr denken dass das ihr katzenklo wäre
dann einfach ein kleines glas schälchen
mit essigessenz vielleicht mehrere und
es mag die katze überhaupt nicht riechen
dann ist es ein gutes einfaches
vergrämung mittel und dann gibt's auch
ein paar pflanzen die katzen einfach
nicht riechen können das sind einmal
lavendel zitronenmelisse und knoblauch
und wenn du kaffeesatz auf dein leben
aus bringst dann stinkt das den katzen
auch ganz gewaltig und sie möchten gar
nicht mehr so gern in deinen garten kann